disfrutando del sol a orillas del río
sena así enfrentaron los parisinos el
primer día del tercer confinamiento
nacional una medida que estará en vigor
al menos un mes y que limita el
movimiento de la población muy cansada
de las restricciones razón por la que se
desplegaron más de 6.600 policías en la
región de ildefons que fueron a los
lugares favoritos de los ciudadanos como
el canal san martín para asegurarse de
que cumplían con las normas
le tengo que pedir que por favor se
ponga el tapabocas
también sobre la nariz señor
con el nuevo confinamiento muchos
parisinos dijeron que disfrutar del buen
tiempo es una necesidad estoy aquí para
tomar el aire para disfrutar del sol
porque no somos hamsters no somos ratas
no podemos quedarnos escondidos en
nuestros agujeros las nuevas medidas
incluyen la restricción del movimiento
de las personas que solo pueden salir a
un radio de 10 kilómetros de su casa sin
un permiso el cierre de las escuelas y
los comercios no esenciales así como el
toque de queda a las 7 de la tarde las
cifras de contagios y muertes han
empeorado en las últimas semanas debido
principalmente a la propagación de la
variante británica más contagiosa un
rebrote que ha hecho que los hospitales
y las unidades de cuidado intensivo
estén al límite
estamos llenos cuando tenemos una cama
libre se vuelve a llenar así que
efectivamente la pensión siempre está
ahí
completo ahora el país tiene puestas las
esperanzas en la vacunación ya que el
gobierno tras meses de carencia en las
dosis ha prometido que aumentará su
despliegue y el ritmo de inoculaciones